Hi, everybody. Welcome to the cold open of this episode of SmartList.
I'm freezing.
You know, it'd be great if Arnette was here to warm this cold open up a little bit.
I don't think he's available.
No, he's not available.
We should just start.
Let's just start.
Oh, God, look at all these goozies on my arm.
大家好。欢迎来到本期《SmartLess》的开场。我快冻僵了。你知道，如果阿内特能在这里让这个开场暖和一点就好了。我觉得他没空。不，他没空。我们还是直接开始吧。我们就开始吧。天哪，看看我胳膊上起的这些鸡皮疙瘩。
Welcome to Smartless.
Guess what I just finished watching moments ago.
A pizza pocket heat up in my arm.
the microwave.
Oh, wait.
Now, let me try.
Yeah.
I wish.
欢迎来到《SmartLess》。猜猜我刚才看完什么了？一个披萨口袋在微波炉里加热。哦，等等。现在，让我试试。是的。我希望是这样。
Something with Scotty.
I don't have it yet.
Your zipper on your pants
not be able to close.
Oh, wait, I know what it is.
It's the top button on your trousers
flying across the room and breaking a light bulb.
No, I just watched the first,
和斯科蒂有关的东西。我还没看完。你裤子的拉链拉不上。哦，等等，我知道是什么了。是你裤子上的顶扣飞过房间，打碎了一个灯泡。不，我刚看完第一集，
literally 10 minutes ago,
finished watching DTF St. Louis,
the first episode.
Oh.
Let me tell you, it is so good.
It is right up my alley.
And Jay, another incredible character by you.
Oh, thank you.
就在10分钟前，刚看完《DTF St. Louis》的第一集。哦。我跟你说，这太棒了。正合我意。还有杰伊，你塑造的另一个不可思议的角色。哦，谢谢。
Like really, like so different.
Really quick question.
Did you say it's a ride up your alley?
It's a ride up your alley.
It's right up your alley. It's right up your alley.
He's been saying it wrong for years, Will.
Don't stop him now.
No, it's right up my alley.
真的，非常不同。问个很快的问题。你是说“right up my alley”（正合我意）吗？是“right up my alley”。是“right up my alley”。他多年来一直说错了，威尔。现在别打断他。不，是“right up my alley”。
The way it's shot and, of course, performed, you're brilliant.
It's so good, Jay.
You're so good in it.
Rider director.
I mean, that's the shot of the swing, that's all I'll say.
Yeah, yeah.
I mean, that's so smart.
It's so cool.
拍摄方式，当然还有表演，你太出色了。太棒了，杰伊。你在里面演得太好了。导演。我是说，那个秋千的镜头，我只能说这些。是的，是的。我是说，那太聪明了。太酷了。
It gets real, real, real, real, real, real crazy.
Yeah, and the ending of the first episode, wow.
It's really good.
Thank you for watching that, you sweet, man.
It's so good.
You're so good.
Do you, I don't know if I've ever admitted this on this show before,
but speaking of saying things wrong for years.
它变得非常、非常、非常、非常、非常、非常疯狂。是的，第一集的结尾，哇。真的太棒了。谢谢你看了那个，你这个贴心的人。太棒了。你演得太好了。我不知道我以前在这个节目里有没有承认过，但说到多年来一直说错话，
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
And this is, I'll attribute this to not reading a lot.
You know, I'm allergic to books, and I'm not proud of that.
Yeah.
Because I feel if I had I seen this written, I wouldn't have,
made the mistake all these years, but I've always thought that when you say the phrase,
I'm just trying to make ends meet.
是的。哦，该死。这得归咎于我读书不多。你知道，我对书过敏，我对此并不引以为豪。是的。因为我觉得如果我见过这句短语的写法，我就不会犯这么多年的错误了，但我一直以为当你用“I'm just trying to make ends meet”（我只是在努力维持生计）这个短语时，
I thought that was a phrase that one would say when they're saying, listen, I'm just trying
to get by with just the bare minimum.
I'm not being greedy.
I'm not entitled.
I'm just trying to make ends meet.
Meaning, I'm just looking for the part of the cow that doesn't cost a lot.
I just need sustenance.
I need some food.
我以为那是当一个人说“听着，我只是在努力用最基本的东西过活。我并不贪婪。我没有权利要求更多。我只是在努力维持生计”时会说的话。意思是，我只是在寻找牛身上不贵的那部分。我只需要维持生命。我需要一些食物。
I'm looking for ends meat, like M-E-A-T, the end of the cow, the ass,
which is not going to cost you a lot.
This is what my stupid head thought until I'm 57.
And this was probably a couple years ago.
I was 55 until I realized that it is ends of, you know, strings or whatever,
creating a circle.
You want these ends to meet and create a whole thing.
which can mean something similar to.
我在寻找“ends meat”，即M-E-A-T，牛的末端，屁股，那部分不会花你很多钱。这就是我愚蠢的脑袋一直以来的想法，直到我57岁。这大概是几年前的事了。我一直以为是那样，直到我意识到它是指“绳子”之类的末端，形成一个圆圈。你想要这些末端相遇并形成一个整体。这可以意味着类似的事情。
I'm just trying to make it all come together for myself.
You're trying to make, well, you're trying to, you're trying to be able to afford stuff.
You're trying to make ends meet, you're trying to do stuff within your budget.
Yeah, it wasn't a proud moment for me, but I'm not beyond admitting my flaws.
I'm just trying to think of like the gotcha headlines and the various social media stuff about this.
Oh, no, this will be cut.
No, this is just for you, me, and your guest, well.
We can't cut this.
我只是在努力让一切对我来说都圆满。你是在努力，嗯，你是在努力让自己负担得起东西。你是在努力维持生计，你是在努力在预算内做事情。是的，那不是我值得骄傲的时刻，但我并不排斥承认自己的缺点。我只是在想关于这个的那些抓眼球的标题和各种社交媒体内容。哦，不，这会被剪掉的。不，这只是为你、我和你的嘉宾准备的，威尔。我们不能剪掉这个。
What kind of cut is that at the end of the cow that you're talking about?
You're talking about your flank steak?
Well, the flank is, it's often called the flank, where the end.
That's not the end.
Wait, but you know that, like, I love, you know that.
Remember, I love, like, sayings and their originate origination, what is I called?
You stupid ass.
Where they originated from.
你说的牛的末端是什么部位？你说的是侧腹牛排吗？嗯，侧腹通常被称为侧腹，末端。那不是末端。等等，但你知道，我喜欢，你知道的。记住，我喜欢谚语及其起源，那叫什么？你这个蠢货。它们起源于哪里。
This is a tough day for me.
Go ahead.
And where they originated from, you know what I mean?
And so remember I did the saved by the bell,
I told you guys about saying by the bell.
You did an episode or an arc?
No, no, where that saying comes from.
Oh.
今天对我来说很难熬。继续吧。它们起源于哪里，你知道我的意思吗？还记得我做过《Saved by the Bell》（被钟声拯救）吗？我告诉过你们关于“saved by the bell”的事。你做过一集还是一个故事线？不，不，是那个说法从哪来的。哦。
Remember the guy, people used to get buried.
Remember I told you?
They used to get buried alive.
And they didn't know it at the time because people were unconscious.
They just thought they were dead.
So they'd bury them in these coffins.
Then they dig them back up to reuse the coffins.
And they saw these scratch marks.
还记得那个人吗，人们过去常被埋葬。记得我告诉过你吗？他们过去常被活埋。当时人们不知道，因为人们处于昏迷状态。他们只是以为他们死了。所以他们把他们埋在棺材里。然后他们把棺材挖出来重复使用。他们看到了抓痕。
So they're like, oh my God, we've been burying people alive.
So they bury people alive.
They tie a string to their toe.
They put it through their.
ground and tie it to a bell
and you're saved by the bell if the bell
goes off. And the person who had to sit there
and wait to see if the bell went off,
所以他们想，天哪，我们一直在活埋人。所以他们活埋人。他们在他们的脚趾上系一根绳子。他们把它穿过地面，系在一个铃铛上，如果铃铛响了，你就被“钟声拯救”了。而那个必须坐在那里等待看铃铛是否响了的人，
worked with the graveyard shift. Wow.
Okay, and this is what you thought
saved by the bell was for years. No, that is
what it is. It's not. It's a boxing thing.
Well, evidently it originated with this, J.B.
That's right. Really? Really? Yes, that's
I'm telling you. Wait, so hang on.
So, Will, you're taking, that's news to you
做的是守墓人的工作。哇。好吧，这就是你多年来认为“saved by the bell”的意思。不，事实就是这样。不是的。那是拳击里的东西。嗯，显然它起源于这个，J.B.。没错。真的吗？真的吗？是的，我告诉你。等等，等一下。所以，威尔，你接受了，这对你来说是新闻
and you're going with Sean? That's news
to me. I do vaguely remember Sean mentioned
this before.
Yeah.
Well, that doesn't make it true.
He's just repeating insanity.
I mean, I'm sure people can just look it up as they're listening to this right now.
I don't know why we would.
而且你还支持肖恩？这对我来说是新闻。我隐约记得肖恩以前提到过这个。是的。嗯，那并不能让它成为事实。他只是在重复疯狂的言论。我是说，我相信人们现在听的时候就可以查一下。我不知道我们为什么要那样做。
That's where it comes from.
We're going to have our fact checkers get on that while we're, while we're, we've got fact checkers now?
Yeah, yeah.
So let's have to do that.
Will, go ahead, introduce your guest and let's get on with that.
Oh, shoot.
Jason.
This is a little runner that I've been having trying to get Will panicked while he's.
这就是它的来源。我们要让我们的事实核查员去查一下，当我们……我们现在有事实核查员了？是的，是的。所以让我们去做那个。威尔，继续，介绍你的嘉宾，让我们继续吧。哦，该死。杰森。这是我一直在玩的一个小梗，试图让威尔在他……的时候感到恐慌。
Did I ever get?
get panicked about it?
No, I don't think it worked.
It's my guest and I'm so excited.
And Willie, I think you're going to be excited too.
I think I remember, I think it was you telling me
that you're just a kooky fan for this fella
and I don't blame you because I am too.
我有没有让他感到恐慌？不，我觉得没用。这是我的嘉宾，我太兴奋了。而且威利，我想你也会很兴奋的。我想我记得，我想是你告诉我你是这家伙的疯狂粉丝，我不怪你，因为我也是。
Gentlemen, I'm not going to care.
No, no.
Great, let's start.
Let's start.
It's going to be a great hour for you, Sean.
No, you will.
Everybody freaks on this guy for very good reason.
Have you searched for the answer to the age-old question?
先生们，我不在乎。不，不。太好了，我们开始吧。我们开始吧。这对你来说会是美好的一小时，肖恩。不，你会的。每个人都因为很好的理由对这家伙感到疯狂。你有没有寻找过那个古老问题的答案？
What should I do after pursuing rock stardom and being a lawyer?
Well, our guest this week has the answer.
You become one of the finest actors on the planet.
You go out there, you work with the best directors in the world,
you turn in some of the most powerful and moving performances ever,
and then you grab yourself an arm full of awards,
including the little gold guy named Oscar.
He's done three careers worth of work already in his 30 years of performing,
在追求摇滚明星梦并成为一名律师之后，我该做什么？嗯，我们本周的嘉宾有答案。你成为地球上最优秀的演员之一。你走出去，与世界上最好的导演合作，贡献出一些有史以来最强大、最动人的表演，然后你抓了一大把奖项，包括那个叫奥斯卡的金人。他在30年的表演生涯中已经完成了三份职业的工作量，
and it's been theater and film and television,
but one of those television projects is now a film,
and he's here to talk to us about that.
Gentlemen, please welcome Tommy Shelby himself,
Mr. Killian Murphy.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, here with us today.
How good.
而且涉及戏剧、电影和电视，但其中一个电视项目现在变成了一部电影，他来这里和我们谈谈那个。先生们，请欢迎汤米·谢尔比本人，基里安·墨菲先生。哦，天哪。是的，今天和我们在一起。太棒了。
Oh, Killian.
How cool.
So nice to meet you.
Hey, man.
Nice to meet you.
That was a lovely introduction.
Thank you.
Right, I worked on it for minutes.
哦，基里安。太酷了。很高兴见到你。嘿，伙计。很高兴见到你。那是一个可爱的介绍。谢谢。没错，我为此准备了几分钟。
What time is it for you today now?
It's like nearly 6pm in London.
Oh, all right.
Now, if you're like me, you're about an hour away from sleep.
Are you in comfy socks?
Are you getting ready to get horizontal?
Or are you about to start your night?
I do start thinking about bed from, yeah, about half past five.
你现在几点了？伦敦快下午6点了。哦，好吧。现在，如果你像我一样，你离睡觉还有大约一个小时。你穿着舒适的袜子吗？你准备好躺平了吗？还是你正要开始你的夜晚？我确实从下午五点半就开始考虑睡觉了。
That is true.
So we're keeping you up right now.
No, I mean, I'm just thinking about it.
Yeah.
But I will be approaching.
I'll be in bed by like half nine.
Right?
You're good.
那是真的。所以我们现在让你熬夜了。不，我是说，我只是在想这件事。是的。但我会接近的。我会在九点半左右上床睡觉。对吧？你很好。
We're all in the same.
It's so nice.
Yeah, I think the four of us are very good at relaxing and taking it easy.
Now, is that because we're of a certain age or is it because we've all really been good at getting after it?
And we're kind of done with that.
Yeah.
Right?
I did it.
我们都在同一个频道。太好了。是的，我想我们四个人都很擅长放松和从容不迫。现在，这是因为我们到了某个年龄，还是因为我们都真的很擅长去追求它？然后我们有点厌倦了。是的。对吧？我做到了。
And now I want to enjoy the relaxation of wisdom and a.
I don't, I mean, what do you guys think?
What's your...
Well, I'm 100% I agree with Jason, although I was going to ask you, Killian, is like the...
I'm doing theater right now, and I know you've done a lot of theater, and it's like,
all of a sudden you have to retrain your brain to have the most energy at 8 p.m.
Yeah, yeah.
You know, and it's like, of the whole day, you have to have most of your energy at 8 p.m.
现在我想享受智慧带来的放松和……我不，我是说，你们怎么看？你们的……嗯，我100%同意杰森的观点，尽管我本来想问你，基里安，就像……我现在正在演戏剧，我知道你演过很多戏剧，就像，突然间你必须重新训练你的大脑，在晚上8点拥有最大的精力。是的，是的。你知道，就像，在这一整天里，你必须在晚上8点拥有大部分精力。
And boy, it's rough.
Are you going on stage tonight?
And tomorrow, my quote-unquote week starts Wednesdays.
And he's doing a one-man show, Killing.
And I think you've done one of those, haven't you?
I certainly have.
Yeah, wow.
Good man.
天哪，这太难了。你今晚要上台吗？还有明天，我的所谓“周”从周三开始。他在演一部独角戏，基里安。我想你演过那种，对吧？我当然演过。是的，哇。好样的。
It's a lot.
That's like the fucking Everest of acting.
That's what I call.
It's very right.
Did you ever have, well, Shani, I haven't asked you.
I'll ask you both at the same time.
Has there been a wipeout yet?
Like a total, like, that's my fear.
这很多。那就像是表演界的珠穆朗玛峰。我是这么叫的。非常正确。你有没有，嗯，肖尼，我还没问你。我同时问你们俩。有没有发生过“崩溃”？就像完全的，就像，那是我的恐惧。
Like, there's no net.
There's no actor you can find the eyes of.
and sort of communicate silently.
I have no idea what I'm supposed to say next.
Throw me a line.
Yeah, my line the other night was,
he tells me, the line is he tells me
two kids came forward to confess to it.
就像，没有安全网。没有你可以找到眼神交流的演员。然后进行无声的交流。我完全不知道接下来该说什么。给我一句台词。是的，我前几天晚上的台词是，他告诉我，台词是他告诉我两个孩子站出来承认了。
It was an accident, that's the line.
And three or four shows ago, literally on stage,
he tells,
oh no.
He's just a panic.
It's just unbelievable.
I mean, you feel like it's 20 minutes long
And I go, teenagers brand their car into them, killed them.
那是意外，这就是台词。而在三四场演出前，就在舞台上，他告诉我，哦，不。他只是恐慌。这简直不可思议。我是说，你觉得那有20分钟那么长，然后我说，青少年把车开向他们，杀了他们。
And then I just started.
By the way, I'm sure the audience probably did not know this.
No, I know.
And for you, it seemed like interminable.
Like, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But isn't the line you have forgotten linked to the line that follows it?
Yes, of course.
And so you can't just improvise the line you can't remember
然后我就开始了。顺便说一句，我相信观众可能不知道这一点。不，我知道。对你来说，这似乎是无止境的。就像，是的，是的，是的。但你忘记的台词不是和紧随其后的台词相连吗？是的，当然。所以你不能只是即兴发挥你记不住的台词，
because that doesn't shine any light on the next thing you're supposed to say.
But you do know the kind of the context.
You just kind of forget the word order.
so then you paraphrase until you get back on the train.
Yeah, you get back on.
So you got right back on and it was all right.
Yeah, yeah, it was fine.
Killian, any nightmare like that?
因为那对你接下来应该说的下一件事没有任何启发。但你确实知道那种语境。你只是有点忘记了词序。所以你就改写，直到你回到正轨。是的，你回到正轨。所以你马上就回去了，一切都还好。是的，是的，没问题。基里安，有那样的噩梦吗？
Yeah.
You know the way, when you're doing theater,
it's like you got like the left-hand side and the right-hand,
so you've got the sort of stage-manager side of your brain
and you've got the acting side of your brain, right?
So you've got the stage-manager side going, right,
you drop the prop back there,
so you've got to go back and pick up the prop while you're saying the lines.
是的。你知道，当你演戏剧时，就像你有左脑和右脑，所以你有舞台监督那一侧的大脑，还有表演那一侧的大脑，对吧？所以你有舞台监督那一侧在说，对，你把道具掉在那后面了，所以你必须回去捡起道具，同时还要说台词。
That's right.
And they're acting similar.
They're running parallel.
So you've got this kind of management in your head going,
well, you've got to fix this,
and then the other side is talking.
So I did probably, but I was, it was like,
没错。没错。它们演得很相似。它们是平行运行的。所以你的脑子里有这种管理，在说，好吧，你必须解决这个问题，然后另一侧在说话。所以我可能做过，但我当时，就像，
I quite liked not having to rely on the, you know,
the terrified eyes across the stage to some other actor,
like saying, can you pick up the fucking knife that was not supposed to.
So I quite enjoyed it.
But what I did find, and I don't know about you, Sean,
I could not sleep after it.
I could not go to sleep.
It's been rough.
我相当喜欢不必依赖舞台对面那些惊恐的眼神，去看向其他演员，就像说，你能捡起那个不该掉的该死的刀吗？所以我相当享受它。但我发现的是，我不知道你怎么样，肖恩，我之后睡不着。我无法入睡。这太难了。
Really?
Yeah.
Just wired.
Yeah. Absolutely. It was like being thrown out of a helicopter. I could not sleep.
How are you about the folks coming backstage and wanting to congratulate you and talk a little bit?
Like, are you, I would imagine that thing. I'm obsessed with this.
I know. Because I don't want to be fucking bothered for the most part at any point in the day.
This will keep you from doing Broadway. This very thing will keep you from doing Broadway.
真的吗？是的。只是处于兴奋状态。是的。绝对是。就像被从直升机上扔下来一样。我无法入睡。你对那些来到后台想祝贺你并聊几句的人感觉如何？就像，你是，我想象那件事。我对此很着迷。我知道。因为我大部分时间都不想被该死的打扰。这会让你无法演百老汇。正是这件事会让你无法演百老汇。
I'm with you though, Jay. I'm with you. But I just feel like I would feel, I would feel burdened to,
to make the person feel comfortable.
Right.
Backstage.
And I would just feel their awkwardness,
and I would feel like I need to host them now.
And I need to, just because I don't want people to feel uncomfortable.
So, like, I'm still working.
不过我和你一样，杰伊。我和你一样。但我只是觉得我会感到负担，去让那个人感到舒服。对吧。在后台。我会感觉到他们的尴尬，我会觉得我现在需要招待他们。我需要，只是因为我不想让人们感到不舒服。所以，就像，我还在工作。
I'm still on.
And do you feel that either one of you guys with that moment, Killian?
Yeah.
And I would be, I think when I was younger,
I would always be up for the, like, come back to the dress.
I mean, we'll have a drink, and we'll go out.
But then as I got older, I just couldn't fake it, I think, any long.
But equally, I couldn't sleep.
我还在状态。你们俩在那个时刻有这种感觉吗，基里安？是的，我想当我年轻的时候，我总是会愿意，就像，回到更衣室。我是说，我们会喝一杯，我们会出去。但后来随着年龄增长，我想我再也装不下去了。但同样，我也睡不着。
So I didn't know what to do.
Like, I didn't go for a long walk, have a bath.
Because the adrenaline, you mean still?
Yeah, and then go to the pub.
I didn't want to go to the pub.
Sit alone, drinking, not a good idea.
So what do you, like, what do you do?
I don't know what to do.
所以我不知道该怎么办。就像，我没有去散步，洗个澡。因为肾上腺素，你是说还在？是的，然后去酒吧。我不想去酒吧。独自坐着，喝酒，不是个好主意。所以你，就像，你做什么？我不知道该做什么。
Yeah.
Well, can I ask you?
This is another thing I'm fascinated with.
And guys, plug yours, you've heard me twat on about this before.
But is it the same practice overseas there that it is apparently in New York where if you are famous, even pseudo famous, you are obligated to go backstage and pay your respects and say hi.
Even if the actor, even if you don't know the actor, any of the actors, and they don't know that you're there.
What I've heard is that it's very rude to just watch the show and leave
if you're of any sort of notoriety.
是的。好吧，我可以问你吗？这是我着迷的另一件事。伙计们，插播你们的，你们以前听我唠叨过这个。但在海外，如果如果你出名，哪怕是伪出名，你是否有义务去后台表示敬意并打个招呼，这是一种惯例吗？即使演员，即使你不认识那个演员，任何演员，他们也不知道你在那里。我听说如果你有任何名气，只看演出就离开是非常粗鲁的。
Is that the same thing over there?
Do you guys go back?
Sometimes.
My other half makes me go back.
So you prefer not to, but you recognize that there is a practice.
There is a tradition, there's an obligation.
There is, yeah.
那边也是这样吗？你们会去后台吗？你们会去后台吗？有时。我的另一半让我去后台。所以你宁愿不去，但你意识到这是一种惯例。这是一种传统，这是一种义务。是的，有。
Yeah, there's like a little pressure.
Like if they know you're in the audience because the stage manager comes up and says,
they would love to say hi or if you would like to
then you kind of have to
then you do that that's just that's just courteous
but if you don't know the person
and they haven't made that connection
I think you're well within your right to just sort of
是的，有一点压力。就像如果他们知道你在观众席，因为舞台监督走过来说，他们很想打个招呼，或者如果你想的话，那么你就有必要，然后你就那样做了，那只是礼貌，但如果你不认识那个人，他们也没有建立那种联系，我认为你有充分的权利只是……
Yeah I mean I've had people come that don't that don't come back
I don't pick I don't think anything about it
Even if they they're not in house seats or anything like that
So there's no way for them to assume that you know that they're there
I went to see Sean in previews
I went to see Sean in previews that I didn't tell them and I just left
I didn't even go and say I don't
Oh it wasn't until we all went together that I went back
是的，我是说，我有人来过，但没有去后台。我没觉得有什么。即使他们没有坐在内部座位上，或者类似的东西。所以他们没有办法假设你知道他们在那里。我去看肖恩的预演，我去看肖恩的预演，我没告诉他们，我就离开了。我甚至没去打招呼。哦，直到我们一起去的时候，我才去后台。
state. Not true, Sean. Not true.
So, Killian, it's the same
thing overseas, as far as
the practice, the tradition? Yeah, I mean, I can't.
People, people
do... I remember once I was
in, I was doing a show in New York and I had a night
off like you have, Sean, and
不是真的，肖恩。不是真的。所以，基里安，在海外，就惯例和传统而言，也是一样吗？是的，我是说，我不能。人们，人们确实……我记得有一次我在纽约演一部戏，我有一个像你一样的休息之夜，肖恩，而且
at the time John Hurt was doing
Crapslas tape, and I went
to see the play and it was unbelievable
and it was, you know, it was John Hurt.
And then stage manager came up and said,
would you like to go back and meet Mr. Hurt?
And I went, I was doing
show at the same time and I thought, would I like
当时约翰·赫特在演《克拉普的最后一盘磁带》，我去看那部戏，简直不可思议，而且，你知道，那是约翰·赫特。然后舞台监督走过来说，你想去后台见见赫特先生吗？我当时也在演戏，我想，我希望
John Hurt came back to see me?
No, I wasn't comparing myself to John Hurt, I was, and I went,
and I went, and I went, I just leave him. So I just left.
And then afterwards I went, you fucking idiot.
Why didn't you not go back and meet John Hurt?
He's like one of my acting heroes.
But I didn't, because I felt he might be a little tired.
And it's like, you're famous, I'm famous,
约翰·赫特来后台见我吗？不，我不是在拿自己和约翰·赫特比，我当时，我当时，我当时，我只是让他离开。所以我只是离开了。然后事后我想，你这个该死的白痴。你为什么不去后台见见约翰·赫特？他是我心目中的表演英雄之一。但我没去，因为我觉得他可能有点累了。而且就像，你出名，我也出名，
so I thought I'd come back and say, hi, that's the thing
that sort of cringes me out about it.
But I hear that it's actually the opposite,
that it's, it's, you should.
Let's bring it up more often, Jay.
Yeah.
Wait, I want to hear about Fillion's musical career.
I didn't know this about you.
所以我以为我会去后台说，嗨，这就是那种让我感到尴尬的事情。但我听说实际上恰恰相反，它是，它是，你应该去。让我们更经常地提出来，杰伊。是的。等等，我想听听基里安的音乐生涯。我不知道你这一点。
Can you expand on that a little bit?
Yeah.
Well, it seems to be, excuse me, it seems to be quite common, doesn't it?
That there's a lot of frustrated musicians in acting.
I've counted lots of them.
Yeah.
And, yeah, it's initially what I'm sure does probably some of you guys are among them,
but that's all I wanted to do from the very beginning was play music.
你能稍微展开讲讲吗？是的。嗯，这似乎很常见，不是吗？演艺界有很多受挫的音乐家。我数过很多。是的。而且，是的，这最初是我确信你们中的一些人可能也是其中之一，但这从一开始就是我唯一想做的事，就是玩音乐。
And when I saw you, Jason, was at the radio head show.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then obviously it didn't work out.
So I kind of moved into theatre, I think,
for to try and get that live experience, you know,
that connection with an audience that you get when you play music.
And then that just became the main thing.
But it was always music, yeah.
当我看到你时，杰森，是在电台司令的演出上。是的，是的，是的。然后显然没成功。所以我转行进入了戏剧，我想，是为了尝试获得那种现场体验，你知道，那种你在玩音乐时与观众建立的联系。然后那成了主要的事情。但一直都是音乐，是的。
And I'm still obsessed with it.
Are you?
My first love of you.
I didn't know that what, are you in a band?
I'm sorry, forgive me.
No, I mean, you should.
Why would you?
He was with his brother.
而且我仍然对此着迷。是吗？我的初恋。我不知道那个，你是在乐队里吗？对不起，原谅我。不，我是说，你应该。你为什么要那样？他和他的兄弟在一起。
And is it true?
Is this a story?
This is Wikipedia facts.
So forgive our rigorous journalism skills.
But you guys were, you guys had a band together.
And then there was a record label that wanted you to sign.
But you were like,
This smells like maybe an overreach, and so let's not sign,
这是真的吗？这是一个故事吗？这是维基百科的事实。所以原谅我们严谨的新闻技巧。但你们，你们曾经有一个乐队在一起。然后有一家唱片公司想让你签约。但你当时想，这闻起来可能有点越权，所以我们别签了，
and then things kind of transitioned into theater,
and that became your passion?
Was that kind of the way it went?
More or less, yeah, more or less.
Like, my brother was still, he was playing keys in the man,
and he was only 16 or something when we were off of the record deal.
So my parents said, absolutely verboten, you're not, like, ruining your life.
You, they said to me, I can ruin my life, but then we just didn't.
然后事情就转到了戏剧，那成了你的热情所在？是那样发展的吗？差不多吧，是的，差不多。就像，我兄弟还在，他在乐队里弹键盘，我们被提供唱片合同时他才16岁左右。所以我父母说，绝对禁止，你不能，就像，毁了你的生活。你，他们对我说，我可以毁了我的生活，但后来我们只是没那样做。
But Patty, we were going to protect.
Yeah. So we, it just all kind of fell apart.
Yeah.
And then I'd never been to the theatre before that.
And then after that I saw a play in Cork City where I'm from, which was like...
Pluckler Orange?
Exactly, yeah.
And it was a promenade version of that play.
但帕蒂，我们要保护。是的。所以我们，一切都分崩离析了。是的。然后在那之前我从未去过剧院。然后在那之后，我在我所在的科克市看了一部戏，那是……《发条橙》？没错，是的。那是那部戏的巡游版本。
And absolutely, absolutely like, I just, it was the greatest thing I'd ever seen.
Had you seen the film before that?
Not at that. It was banned in Ireland.
Oh, really?
It was banned in Ireland.
The first time I saw it was I bought a VHS copy of it in Canada.
Wow.
Yeah.
而且绝对，绝对就像，我只是，那是我见过最伟大的事情。在那之前你看过电影吗？没看过。它在爱尔兰被禁了。哦，真的吗？它在爱尔兰被禁了。我第一次看是在加拿大买的录像带。哇。是的。
That's wild.
My grandpa's from Dingell.
We love it in Canada.
We love it.
My grandfather's from Dingell.
My grandmother is from County Kerry.
Yeah.
Oh, man.
那太疯狂了。我爷爷来自丁格尔。我们在加拿大很喜欢它。我们很喜欢。我爷爷来自丁格尔。我奶奶来自凯里郡。是的。哦，伙计。
I mean, I spent a lot of time in Dingle and around the West of the world.
It's beautiful, right?
Shawnee, have you been over there?
Yeah.
Just once.
It's just
to Ding, I mean to Ireland
a couple times, but to Dingle just once,
我是说，我在丁格尔和世界西部周围花了很多时间。很美，对吧？肖尼，你去过那边吗？是的。只有一次。只是去丁格尔，我是说去爱尔兰几次，但去丁格尔只有一次，
I still have a, I still, we have still have cousins,
like distant cousins, I think that still live there.
But yeah, it's really pretty old.
I still have a sweatshirt that says, I got this.
Dingleberry.
So the first
time you really experienced
the theaters when you saw Clockwork Orange on stage,
我仍然有一个，我仍然，我们仍然有表亲，我想是远房表亲，仍然住在那里。但是的，它真的很漂亮。我仍然有一件运动衫，上面写着，我得到了这个。丁格尔莓。所以你真正体验戏剧的第一次是你看到舞台上的《发条橙》，
yeah, is that what your, is that
what your testimony is?
Do we have your answer, right?
Yeah.
Well, how did that, how did that moment go?
Because your parents are both educators, yes?
Correct, yeah.
And so this conversation of, hey, I've got good news and even better news.
是的，这就是你的，这就是你的证词吗？我们得到你的答案了吗，对吧？是的。嗯，那一刻是怎么发生的？因为你的父母都是教育工作者，对吧？没错，是的。所以这个对话，嘿，我有个好消息，还有更好的消息。
I'm stopping my pursuit of rock and roll and I'm going into theater.
Was that, were they, were they buoyed?
by that or were they like, no, Killian,
were they all right with it?
Like, I was, you mentioned I had a very short flirtation with like law.
I did like a year of a law degree and I failed like abysmally.
And then I tried to get the repeats and then I got the repeats and then I got a part of the play.
So I think by that stage, Jade kind of got like, whatever.
我停止了对摇滚乐的追求，我要进入戏剧界。那是，他们，他们被那个鼓舞了吗？还是他们就像，不，基里安，他们还好吗？就像，我，你提到我曾有过非常短暂的法律方面的调情。我读了一年法律学位，我失败得一塌糊涂。然后我尝试参加重考，然后我参加了重考，然后我得到了一部戏的角色。所以我认为到那个阶段，杰伊，他们有点像，随便吧。
Just he's going to do, he's going to do his thing.
You know, I was 20 then.
So that's when you're meant to make mistakes, isn't it?
Of course.
And declare, I'm not really sure, but I'm following some instincts, and those are going to change.
Listen, Killing, I'm continuing making mistakes and I'm 55.
Yes, you're all the same.
Right.
他只是要去做，他要去做他的事。你知道，我那时20岁。所以那是你注定要犯错的时候，不是吗？当然。并宣布，我不太确定，但我正在跟随一些直觉，而那些直觉会改变。听着，基里安，我还在不断犯错，我已经55岁了。是的，你们都一样。没错。
I am, as I said the other day, I'm firmly in the student section in life.
I've finally come to that realization that I'm like, it's okay.
Well, your tan and the ceiling fan looks like you're doing all right right now.
It is. I know it's really going.
I'm sorry about that.
I had to walk around and find the best place to get internet.
I'm not kidding.
Checking out what had the best.
我，正如我前几天所说，我坚定地站在人生的学生区。我终于意识到，我就像，没关系。嗯，你的晒黑和吊扇看起来你现在做得很好。是的。我知道它真的在进行。对此我很抱歉。我不得不四处走动，找到最好的地方来获取互联网。我没开玩笑。看看什么有最好的。
It's right here with the fanbombo.
You've got a monkey on a wheel.
You know, just keeping the Wi-Fi going.
But I'm curious about you deciding to try to get a law degree, like that decision.
And then while you're doing that, thinking the whole time, wait a second, I'd rather be doing theater.
Like, I've been affected by this.
I've got this thought.
Is that kind of, how did that all kind of transcend?
就在这儿，和风扇在一起。你有一个在轮子上跑的猴子。你知道，只是让Wi-Fi保持运行。但我很好奇你决定尝试获得法律学位，那个决定。然后在你做那个的时候，一直想，等一下，我宁愿去演戏。就像，我受到了这个的影响。我有这个想法。那是那种，这一切是怎么超越的？
inspire.
I think I just had that natural inclination to perform, which I'm sure you guys are familiar
with, you know, just from the very early age.
I'm quite a shy person, but I really enjoy getting up on a stage.
I hate getting up on stages myself, but I love getting up on stage as someone else
or playing music.
Isn't that a weird thing where, you know, I think all four of us are, you know, proudly private
people.
启发。我想我只是有那种表演的自然倾向，我相信你们很熟悉，你知道，从很小的时候开始。我是一个很害羞的人，但我真的很喜欢站在舞台上。我自己讨厌站在舞台上，但我喜欢作为别人站在舞台上或玩音乐。那不是一件奇怪的事情吗，你知道，我想我们四个人都是，你知道，自豪的私密的人。
we don't we're not we're not shy per se because of what we do but like isn't it isn't it an interesting
thing where we'll sit there in front of the camera and be exposed to millions and millions of people
you know wanting uh hoping in a perfect world millions of people are going to watch what i am doing
yet we we sort of shy away from being um you know the center of attention uh often when we when we go
out or even when we go out to promote that thing that we want people to see we're sort of like
I mean I'll speak for myself it's just like I got to go out and talk about it over here and over
there and kind of light my hair on fire it is sort of the the two things are kind of at odds with
one another the one's controlled and one isn't yeah that's a very good point that's true that's true
我们不是，我们不是害羞本身，因为我们所做的事情，但就像，这不是一件有趣的事情吗，我们会坐在摄像机前，暴露在数百万数百万的人面前，你知道，想要……希望在一个完美的世界里，数百万的人会看我在做什么，然而我们，我们有点回避成为，嗯，你知道，注意力的中心，通常当我们出去时，甚至当我们出去推广我们想让人们看到的东西时，我们有点像，我是说，我为自己说话，就像我必须出去谈论它，在这里和那里，有点像把我的头发点着了，这两件事有点相互矛盾，一个是受控的，一个是没受控的。是的，这是一个很好的观点，那是真的，那是真的。
what's your what's your what's your favorite way uh Killian to interact with fans like when is it when is it
comfortable for you.
I think I know what my answer would be.
Well, tell me yours, because tell me yours.
I feel if it's one-on-one and them, us talking is not going to cause a larger sort of spectacle
and cause a scene.
Like I don't want to embarrass myself, my kids, them, you know, create a, so like in an elevator.
If it's just me and one person and, you know,
你最喜欢的方式，嗯，基里安，与粉丝互动，就像什么时候对你来说是舒服的。我想我知道我的答案会是什么。嗯，告诉我你的，因为告诉我你的。我觉得如果是一对一，我们谈话不会引起更大的那种场面，也不会引起骚动。就像我不想让自己尴尬，我的孩子，他们，你知道，创造一个，所以就像在电梯里。如果只是我和一个人，而且，你知道，
And we can have a little conversation as opposed to, oh, take a picture here and then people walking by look at what's going on here.
Oh, maybe I should get a picture too.
Oh, yeah, I recognize that person.
And then it becomes a thing.
And then, I don't know.
I like sort of the one-on-one stuff.
What about you?
I'm the same, yeah.
我们可以进行一点对话，而不是，哦，在这里拍张照片，然后路过的人看着这里发生了什么。哦，也许我也应该拍张照片。哦，是的，我认出那个人了。然后它就变成了一件事。然后，我不知道。我喜欢那种一对一的东西。你呢？我也一样，是的。
Yeah.
I love a chat.
I love a real chat and someone has really enjoyed something you've done.
Right.
Like, particularly, like, you know, we've all been in shows that have run a long time and people love.
the people are very invested in characters, right?
Sure.
And so you have to acknowledge that investment
是的。我喜欢聊天。我喜欢真正的聊天，有人真的很喜欢你做过的事情。对吧。就像，特别是，就像，你知道，我们都演过运行很长时间的节目，人们很喜欢。人们对角色投入了很多，对吧？当然。所以你必须承认那种投入，
and that they've spent that much time with your characters.
And I love those conversations, you know?
I don't like when stuff gets like fetishized.
He's going to the shop to buy milk, my God.
He's just like us.
Right.
But I love a conversation.
而且他们花了很多时间在你的角色上。我喜欢那些对话，你知道吗？我不喜欢事情变得像被崇拜一样。他去商店买牛奶，天哪。他就像我们一样。对吧。但我喜欢对话。对吧。
And we will be right back.
And now back to the show.
Are you able at times to have the same kind of experience with your characters that some of your fans might?
In other words, are you able to watch what you do and enjoy it from an audience point of view?
Or can you not get the separation from your experience inside the character?
That's a great question
And I'd love to hear what you guys think about it
Well start with
我们马上回来。现在回到节目。你有时能和你的角色有同样的体验吗，就像你的一些粉丝可能有的那样？换句话说，你能从观众的角度观看你所做的事情并享受它吗？还是你无法从角色内部的体验中分离出来？这是一个很好的问题，我很想听听你们对此有什么看法。嗯，从……开始。
Do you watch your own stuff
Or are you an actor that
Because I know both
Both very very good actors
That watch themselves and learn from that
And then others that they can't
And they won't
Well it's different jobs sometimes
你看你自己的东西吗？还是你是一个演员，因为我知道两者，两者都非常非常好的演员，看自己并从中学习。然后其他人，他们不能。他们不会。嗯，有时是不同的工作。
Like this Peeky Blinders film
Like we had the premiere last night
In Birmingham
I just watched it two nights ago
It's incredible
Incredible
I can't wait
It was very cool
就像这部《浴血黑帮》电影，就像我们昨晚在伯明翰的首映式。我两天前刚看完。太不可思议了。不可思议。我等不及了。太酷了。
and what I was producer on that
so I've seen the thing like 500 times
so you know
I like it was a very
different kind of experience
watching it too
you know when you just turn up and as an actor for hire
and you do your work and then you see it
而且我是那部戏的制片人，所以我看过那东西大概500次了，所以你知道，我喜欢它，这是一种非常不同的体验，看着它，你知道，当你只是作为一个受雇的演员出现，你做你的工作，然后你看到它。
and some stuff I've never seen it all
and some stuff I'm immensely proud of
but again I mean
I feel like I try to move forward
with everything then it's like
about the next thing
rather than going backwards.
What about you guys?
有些东西我从来没看过，有些东西我非常自豪，但同样，我是说，我觉得我试图在每件事上都向前看，然后就像是关于下一件事，而不是向后看。你们呢？
What's your take on it?
Do any of you sit around watching your work
endlessly?
That's how I wake up every morning.
I can't get out of bed without it.
That's your alarm.
What about on set?
Will you ever watch a little bit of playback?
你们对此有什么看法？你们中有人坐着无休止地看自己的作品吗？我每天早上醒来都是这样。没有它我就起不了床。那是你的闹钟。那在片场呢？你会看一点回放吗？
Even at the beginning of the production,
just to get a sense of how you're coming across,
how they're lighting you,
the lenses, or just to get a feel of the tone of it.
Occasionally, particularly for technical stuff.
You know, like stuff that's technical or like a stunt or whatever.
But I know I would never go back and look at like a big emotional stuff.
But the producing thing has been interesting because it takes the curse off it a little bit.
即使在制作初期，只是为了了解你的表现如何，他们是如何给你打光的，镜头，或者只是为了感受一下基调。偶尔，特别是对于技术性的东西。你知道，就像技术性的东西，或者特技之类的。但我知道我永远不会回去看像大的情感戏。但制片的事情很有趣，因为它稍微减轻了它的诅咒。
You know, you look at it and you just go, oh my God, that's how you look.
And then you just go, right.
But it's important for this character to do this and this guy's got to enter here
and she's got to say this and we've got to cut here.
And then it takes a curse off it.
Sure.
Well, you look at it and you look at it through a different lens, obviously, right?
So you just, like this thing that I did last year,
你知道，你看着它，你只是说，天哪，你看起来是那样的。然后你只是说，对。但这对于这个角色来说很重要，要做这个，这个家伙必须在这里进入，她必须说这个，我们必须在这里剪辑。然后它减轻了它的诅咒。当然。嗯，你看着它，你显然是通过不同的镜头看着它，对吧？所以你只是，就像我去年做的这件事，
I spend a lot of time having to watch different cuts and stuff
and eventually got to a place where I got over watching myself
and was actually able to watch it really objectively.
Yes.
About, wait, are we telling the best version of the story?
We should go back.
We should tell you, are we telling the best version?
Is this the best thing?
我花了很多时间不得不看不同的剪辑之类的，最终到了一个我不再看自己的地步，实际上能够非常客观地观看它。是的。关于，等等，我们在讲故事的最佳版本吗？我们应该回去。我们应该告诉你，我们在讲最佳版本吗？这是最好的东西吗？
But all these kinds of things, you know.
And it did, as you say, sort of break the curse a little bit.
I was no longer watching my performance.
I was watching a bigger thing.
Yeah.
just sort of being an audience number.
Zero.
但所有这些事情，你知道。而且它确实，正如你所说，稍微打破了诅咒。我不再看我的表演了。我在看一个更大的东西。是的。只是作为观众的一员。零。零。
I always think I'm slightly better looking than I actually am.
And then I'll watch it.
I'll go, no, then.
No, you're not.
You're not at all, actually.
Turned it off.
Close to being what you thought you looked like.
I know.
我总是认为我比我实际看起来稍微好看一点。然后我会看它。我会说，不，然后。不，你不是。你根本不是。关掉它。接近你以为你看起来的样子。我知道。
Well, Killion, was there, speaking of music and then law and all this,
was there ever a moment where, and thank God you didn't,
But was there ever a moment where you thought, yeah, maybe this acting thing, let's put that in the bin as well.
Let's try career path number four and go into industry X or occupation Y.
Did you ever think about giving up on doing this?
No, really. After a period, you kind of like, you burnt your bridges, I think.
And there's nothing else available really.
And during the fallow periods, obviously, get really cranky.
嗯，基里安，有没有，说到音乐，然后法律和所有这些，有没有一个时刻，谢天谢地你没那样做，但有没有一个时刻你认为，是的，也许这个表演的事情，我们也把它扔进垃圾桶吧。让我们尝试职业道路四，进入行业X或职业Y。你有没有想过放弃做这个？不，真的。过了一段时间，你有点像，你烧毁了你的桥梁，我想。而且真的没有其他可用的东西了。而在休耕期，显然，变得非常暴躁。
what the fuck is it
but and I don't like I'm not a writer
I'm definitely not a writer and
so I didn't have that
but I would go and play music in the kind of
fallow bits or just you know
just go and just watch movies and read books but
it is I didn't know I never
那到底是什么，但我不像，我不是作家，我绝对不是作家，所以我没有那个，但我会去玩音乐，在那种休耕期，或者只是，你知道，只是去，只是看电影和读书，但它是，我不知道，我从来没有
got to the stage where I thought
ah fuck this but I did
whenever the stuff started to get kind of dry up in film or television
I was very lucky to have a friend of mine
called Enda Walsh who I made a little
awful lot of theater with and we did some really great plays he gave me my first ever play part in a
play after i saw clock garange when i was like 19 to 20 and so i continued to work with him making like
new plays throughout my 30s and 40s and that kind of kept me sane i think you know when this stuff
到过那种我想，啊，去他的，但我确实，每当电影或电视里的东西开始干涸时，我非常幸运有一个朋友叫恩达·沃尔什，我和他一起做了很多戏剧，我们做了一些非常棒的戏，他在我19到20岁看到《发条橙》后，给了我第一部戏的角色，所以我继续和他合作，在我的30多岁和40多岁制作像新戏一样的东西，那让我保持理智，我想，你知道，当这些东西
kind of just people aren't calling you know yeah wow that's great that's great so you established like
So long ago, this collaboration,
and you've managed to sort of keep it going for all these years.
Yeah, I haven't done a play in a while now
because it's kind of become a little terrifying to me.
Honestly, I'm a little scared of.
Is it because you're worried about Jason Bateman coming backstage
and saying, hi, for the show?
有点只是人们不给你打电话，你知道，是的，哇，那太棒了，那太棒了，所以你建立了，很久以前，这种合作，而且你设法在这些年里一直保持下去。是的，我现在已经有一段时间没演戏了，因为它对我来说变得有点可怕了。老实说，我有点害怕。是因为你担心杰森·贝特曼会来到后台说，嗨，为了演出？
Is that what's keeping you away?
Killian, it's me again.
I've come back for one more night.
I'm just outside.
I want every theater to put up Jason's picture backstage
do not let this guy back here.
Super eager will not leave.
So you start going to try to do it
那是让你远离的原因吗？基里安，又是我。我又回来了一晚。我就在外面。我希望每个剧院都在后台贴上杰森的照片，不要让这家伙进来。超级渴望，不会离开。所以你开始尝试去做它，
and they're like, no, no, we're good.
It's the main reason I did this podcast
so that we could talk about it, actually.
Send up the warning.
Is there something that you have...
Is there some sort of advice
that you have...
you've gained with your experience now?
然后他们就像，不，不，我们很好。这是我做这个播客的主要原因，这样我们实际上可以谈论它。发出警告。有什么你……有什么建议是你……你现在通过你的经验获得的吗？
That you wish you could go back and tell that dude
back then that...
Don't worry about the fallow periods.
It's going to be, is there something that you wish you would have known then
that would have made those ups and those downs a bit more tolerable?
Yeah.
This is a great question.
I mean, aside from, don't worry, you're going to win an Oscar one day.
你希望你能回到过去告诉那个时候的那个家伙……别担心休耕期。它会是，有什么你希望你当时知道的，会让那些起起落落变得更容易忍受吗？是的。这是一个很好的问题。我是说，除了，别担心，你有一天会赢得奥斯卡。
Hang in there.
Yeah.
You know?
Yeah, that would definitely lighten the mood.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I think it's that thing about overthinking stuff, you know, overthinking it,
over-intellectualizing everything.
坚持住。是啊。你知道吗？是啊，那绝对能缓和气氛。是啊。我不知道。我觉得这就是那种过度思考的问题，你知道，想得太多，把一切都过度知性化了。
and not sticking to your instinct, I think, is the key thing for artists.
I know, but what is that, I know, but what is that healthy balance?
Because I've always heard that with everything in life, with all of us.
I think we've all heard somebody say as, ah, you're overthinking it.
But, like, isn't, how do you know what the difference is between overthinking and just simply,
you're just using the intelligence that you've been working on?
You know, it's like, we work.
hard to be smart, or at least we think that we're smart.
对于艺术家来说，我认为关键在于不要违背自己的直觉。我知道，但什么是健康的平衡呢？因为我一直听说生活中所有的事情，我们所有人都是这样。我想我们都听过别人说，啊，你这是想太多了。但是，你怎么知道过度思考和仅仅运用你一直在磨练的智慧之间的区别呢？你知道，就像我们努力变得聪明，或者至少我们认为自己很聪明。
And so how do you know when to pull back on that?
I just don't know.
Well, what's your guys approach to like prep then, for example?
Because sometimes I would get so over, it would just take up everything and everything
we're all consuming.
But then the whole point when you get into a scene is that you have to be completely
free of all that.
Yeah, no idea.
那么你怎么知道什么时候该收敛一点呢？我真的不知道。好吧，那你们对准备工作有什么看法呢？因为有时候我会想得太多，它会占据一切，占据我们所消耗的一切。但当你进入一个场景时，重点是你必须完全摆脱所有这些。是啊，不知道。
So it's kind of counterintuitive or counterproductive to have a lot of that prep sometimes.
but yet you think your duty is to do all of that.
So what, what, how, how, what have you arrived?
It's shifted for me.
I was, I was different from Jason because I was blown away that,
and maybe you do this too will.
Do, do this too will.
所以有时候做太多的准备工作有点违背直觉或适得其反。但你又认为做所有这些是你的职责。那么，你们是怎么得出的结论呢？对我来说已经改变了。对我来说已经改变了。我和杰森不同，因为我感到非常震惊，也许你也这样做，威尔。你也这样做，威尔。
It's like I make sure I'm off book completely from the first time I step on set
or walk out on the rehearsal room or whatever it is.
Because if I, if I'm having my book in my hand or whatever,
I just can't be free, like you're saying, Kalyan, to explore and bring.
where Jason has said in the past, where you don't make choices,
you just literally memorize the words and then you work on it in rehearsal.
But I don't even memorize the words because my part in the term process,
when I memorize has a lot to do with my imagination of kind of how that's going to kind of go.
就像我确保从我第一次踏上片场或走进排练室的那一刻起，我就完全脱稿了。因为如果我手里拿着剧本什么的，我就无法像你说的凯利安那样自由地去探索和发挥。而杰森过去常说，你不做选择，你只是逐字逐句地背下来，然后在排练中去打磨。但我甚至不背台词，因为在我的创作过程中，我背台词时，很大程度上与我对事情将如何发展的想象有关。
And I don't like to decide or start to approach a decision of how I'm going to do something
until I see and understand what the other actors are going to be doing.
and what the director is looking for
and how the scene is blocked
and where camera's going to be
and all this stuff.
Because if I predetermined
how I'm going to do something
我不喜欢在看到并理解其他演员要做什么，导演在寻找什么，场景是如何调度的，摄像机要在哪里等等之前，就决定或开始决定我要怎么做。因为如果我预先决定了我要怎么做，
and what my faces are going to look like
and the wires are going to work
with what the other people are doing.
You've got that book of faces.
I know you've got that book of polarize.
I've got those memorized.
I started doing, I started memorizing
in really monotone ways.
以及我的表情会是什么样子，这些会如何与其他人所做的事情配合。你有那本表情书。我知道你有那本表情书。我已经把那些背下来了。我开始用非常单调的方式背诵。
It's truly, I started memorizing
monotone way and recording myself.
This is true.
And with a very monotone voice
so that I had zero inflection and crossing out all stage direction.
And just taking all of that away.
And I did get into a situation I was working on this thing.
And I got there and they're like,
真的，我开始用单调的方式背诵并录下自己。这是真的。用非常单调的声音，这样我就没有任何语调变化，并划掉所有的舞台指示。只是把所有这些都去掉。我确实遇到过这种情况，我当时正在处理这件事。我到了那里，他们说，
now you've got to go and get the thing on the other side of the room.
I'm like, oh, do I?
I didn't even know that I had it.
You know, but because I, but actually it was very helpful
because it just happened very organically
and I hadn't thought about that.
And so it's really shifted as I've gotten older
how I look at it
现在你得去房间另一边拿那个东西。我说，哦，是吗？我甚至不知道我有它。你知道，但因为我，但实际上这非常有帮助，因为它发生得非常自然，我之前没想过。所以随着年龄的增长，我看待它的方式真的改变了，
and my preparation is so much different
now than it was.
And also, J.B., I think about, like,
when we used to do
Arrested Development, for instance,
it was much more...
Sean, it's a TV show.
Yeah, it's a TV show.
我的准备工作现在和以前大不相同了。还有，J.B.，我想起我们以前做《发展受阻》的时候，它更……肖恩，那是个电视节目。是啊，那是个电视节目。
It used to be a band.
We got sued by them.
I think for...
I think for when you're...
I used to think about it sort of prepping
to do comedy, especially,
because it was so quick and it would happen
so that it didn't serve,
它曾经是个乐队。我们被他们起诉了。我想是因为……我想当你……我过去常想，特别是为喜剧做准备，因为它节奏很快，而且发生得很快，所以它并没有服务于，
me certainly and I know that you were similar in this way J.B.
Because we did a lot of scenes together.
That it was, you just kept it.
It was all kind of just at the surface until you got there.
Right, because that puts, that increases my odds of reacting to you
like the audience is experiencing it.
Yeah, it's so much about rhythm and comedy in that way.
Rhythm is the big thing, I think.
我当然是这样，我知道你在这一点上和我很像，J.B.。因为我们一起拍了很多场景。它就是，你只是保持住。直到你到达那里之前，一切都只是浮于表面。对，因为这增加了我像观众体验那样对你做出反应的几率。是啊，在喜剧方面，节奏非常重要。我认为节奏是关键。
The meaning can come after the rhythm or I guess for you guys,
like if the comedy or the gag or the bit,
that comes out.
But like if you get into a rhythm in a scene,
and I guess if you have a predetermined rhythm,
then how are you going to lock in with anyone else?
You can't, you can't, and you can't,
you need to stay nimble to allow for shit to happen.
意义可以在节奏之后出现，或者我想对你们来说，如果喜剧、笑话或桥段出来了。但如果你进入了一个场景的节奏，我想如果你有一个预设的节奏，那你怎么能和别人合拍呢？你不能，你不能，你需要保持灵活，以便让事情自然发生。
But I do think it's different for a theater
because I would be the same as you, Sean,
like with a theater piece,
I would be completely off book when I get to rehearsed.
But you also have, and here's the difference.
You also have a theater.
By the time you get there,
and you're in rehearsal,
但我确实认为戏剧有所不同，因为我会和你一样，肖恩，对于戏剧作品，当我开始排练时，我会完全脱稿。但你也有，这就是区别。你也有一个剧场。当你到达那里，开始排练时，
I mean, Sean, I know you, for instance, in this,
and also for Good Night Oscar.
What a show!
That you were completely off book.
Yeah, I had to you.
But then you get into previews,
and now you've got a couple weeks of previews.
And it changes.
我是说，肖恩，我知道你，比如在这个戏里，还有《晚安奥斯卡》。多棒的演出啊！你完全脱稿了。是啊，我必须这样做。但当你进入预演阶段，现在你有几周的预演时间。它会改变。
And it changes, and that starts to eat away
at all your predeterminate stuff that you have.
But you don't have that luxury
when you're making a film or making a show.
It's, it's the performance is that day.
And that's it.
Yeah, it's funny. You know, it's funny. There is this one line where I reference a very famous musical in this current show. And one of the producers of this famous musical came to the show and didn't like that we mentioned his musical that he produced. So it's a 75-minute monologue. It's just me. And so we had to change the one word to another musical. And so from the time you started, all I thought about from the time the curtain opened was that one word I had to change.
it right now.
它会改变，这开始侵蚀你所有的预设内容。但当你制作电影或节目时，你没有那种奢侈。表演就是在那一天。就是这样。是啊，很有趣。你知道，很有趣。有一句台词，我在现在的演出中引用了一部非常著名的音乐剧。这部著名音乐剧的制作人之一来看了演出，不喜欢我们提到他制作的音乐剧。所以这是一个75分钟的独角戏。只有我一个人。所以我们不得不把那个词改成另一部音乐剧。所以从我开始的那一刻起，从大幕拉开的那一刻起，我脑子里想的都是那个我必须改掉的词。现在就改。
And I was like, oh, shit.
From the time you started.
Yeah.
I was like, thanks a lot, dude.
All right.
Killing, 28 days later.
That was,
我当时想，哦，该死。从你开始的那一刻起。是啊。我当时想，多谢了，伙计。是啊。好吧。凯利安，《惊变28天》。那是，
first film?
No.
No, I've done a few films in Ireland,
kind of small independent films in Ireland.
This is the one that,
what a film.
Yeah.
Put you on a lot.
第一部电影？不。不，我在爱尔兰拍过几部电影，是一些小型独立电影。这是那部，多棒的电影啊。是啊。让你出现在很多人的视野里。
of a lot of radars.
I guess so, yeah.
Yeah, and did it feel like, okay, I've got a little bit of wind at my back now,
and this might work out?
Yes?
Yeah, yeah, I think so.
At that stage, the film, like, we never expected the film to do well,
and it did well.
我想是吧，是啊。是啊，感觉像是，好吧，我现在背后有一点顺风了，这可能会成功？是吗？是啊，是啊，我想是这样。在那个阶段，这部电影，我们从没指望它会表现得这么好，但它确实表现得很好。
But you did have Danny Boyle.
I mean, you knew your odds were good, right?
They were good.
They were, because he's a master.
And I had like his posters of his films on my wall
and my bedroom growing up, you know,
before I ever became an actor,
because they were just so cool, like trainsprouting and shallow grave.
但你有丹尼·博伊尔。我是说，你知道你的胜算很大，对吧？胜算很大。确实，因为他是大师。我从小在卧室墙上就贴着他电影的海报，你知道，在我成为演员之前，因为它们太酷了，比如《猜火车》和《浅坟》。
I love trains.
And I mean, it's a masterpiece.
But the thing about it was that zombie genre was,
wasn't very cool at the time or it wasn't really like,
there hadn't been a kind of a zombie thing.
Right.
And even though this is technically like an infection,
they're not undead.
我喜欢《猜火车》。我是说，那是一部杰作。但关于它的一点是，僵尸题材在当时并不流行，或者说它并不是真的，当时还没有那种僵尸片。对。即使从技术上讲，这更像是感染，他们不是不死族。
But anyway, at that time that we shot it,
like it was the summer of 2001,
and then obviously like 9-11 happened.
But before that, SARS had happened.
And then obviously all those years later,
like COVID happened,
and it became this kind of meme.
It's a very prescient writing, very good writing.
但无论如何，在我们拍摄的时候，那是2001年的夏天，然后显然发生了9-11事件。但在那之前，SARS已经发生了。然后显然多年后，COVID发生了，它变成了一种模因。这是非常有预见性的写作，非常好的写作。
Yeah.
And people went nuts for it, the original movie.
So, yeah, it was a great,
It's the start.
But I went through the ringer for that movie.
Danny, I had like five or six auditions for that to get the parks.
It done very little at the time.
I kind of knew it was a real substantial script.
是啊。人们为它疯狂，那部原版电影。所以，是的，那很棒，这是个开始。但我为那部电影受尽了折磨。丹尼，我为了得到这个角色试镜了五六次。当时我做得很少。我当时就知道这是一个非常扎实的剧本。
Alex Garland wrote the script and Danny directed him.
Great writer.
Yeah.
He was such a great writer and an amazing director.
Amazing director.
What was the moment from your last audition?
When did you find out that you got it after going through all this auditions and being like, Jesus Christ?
You remember that moment?
亚历克斯·加兰写了剧本，丹尼执导。伟大的编剧。是啊。他是一位如此伟大的编剧和了不起的导演。了不起的导演。你最后一次试镜是什么时候？在经历了所有这些试镜并觉得，天哪，之后，你什么时候发现你得到了这个角色？你还记得那个时刻吗？
You remember where you were?
I do actually.
I was in a, I was in Stansted Airport in the queue
to get a Ryanair flight back to Dublin.
And Danny called me.
I had to do one of those like unbelievably contained celebrations.
Like drop my bag and sit down and kind of, but yeah, it was massive for me.
That movie.
你记得你在哪里吗？我确实记得。我当时在斯坦斯特德机场，排队等着坐瑞安航空的航班回都柏林。丹尼给我打了电话。我不得不进行那种难以置信的克制庆祝。比如放下包坐下来，但是的，那对我来说意义重大。那部电影。
It's fucking 23 years ago or something.
Wow.
Now, he talks often, doesn't he, about energy over perfection?
Do I have that right?
His sort of his MO on set.
Can you explain what he might mean by that?
What his direction, his environment is like, what that set is like, what his style is like?
Sounds about it right.
那是23年前的事了。哇。现在，他经常谈论能量胜过完美，对吧？我没说错吧？他在片场的行事风格。你能解释一下他可能是什么意思吗？他的指导、他的环境是什么样的，那个片场是什么样的，他的风格是什么样的？听起来差不多。
He's incredible energy and passion for it.
Like he never stops moving.
He never stops.
like he's on every single element of the set
and it's constant ideas,
constant, he's constantly pushing, you know,
and really pushing the actors
and pushing every department.
他有令人难以置信的能量和热情。他从不停下脚步。他从不停止。他关注片场的每一个细节，不断有想法，不断地推动，你知道，真的在推动演员和每个部门。
And I absolutely love that at that age.
I don't think I'd been in, you know,
working with someone who was so coherent
in their vision for the film, if you know what I mean.
Yeah, sure, just full enthusiasm and just knows all four corners of what this scene's supposed to do and how it's supposed to be done.
Yeah. And it's infectious. And every time you think, oh, that was pretty good. Like, you know, you're off again.
And we shot that on domestic cameras, like these little, do you remember in the early 2000s?
Everyone had these little cameras with, like, cards in them and stuff.
在那个年纪，我绝对喜欢这一点。我想我之前没有和这样的人合作过，他们的电影愿景如此连贯，你明白我的意思吗？是啊，当然，充满热情，并且知道这个场景应该做的所有四个角落，以及它应该如何完成。是啊。而且很有感染力。每次你觉得，哦，那已经很好了。就像，你知道，他又开始了。我们用家用摄像机拍摄了那部电影，就像2000年代初的那些小摄像机，你还记得吗？每个人都有这些带卡的小摄像机之类的东西。
So they're all like stuff you could buy.
Like camcorders almost. Yeah.
Yeah. They were slightly more advanced. I can't remember what, at the first.
format is.
But anyway, it was just one of those movies that kind of clicked, you know.
Yeah.
A style that I would imagine is, is it wildly different than, you know, what an incredible
所以它们都是你可以买到的东西。几乎就像摄像机。是啊。是啊。它们稍微先进一点。我不记得格式是什么了。但无论如何，这只是那种一拍即合的电影之一，你知道。是啊。是啊。我想象这种风格与你和克里斯托弗·诺兰的合作有很大不同，对吧？
collaboration you've had with Christopher Nolan?
Yeah, I was going to get to it.
Incredible.
That from what I, from what I understand, what I've heard is a more exacting and and, and
contained and deliberate approach to the execution, yes or no?
And to the extent you're comfortable talking about it,
because I would assume that environments on sets,
well, not assume, I know, they're often private,
是啊，我正要说到这个。不可思议。据我所知，我听说这是一种更严谨、更克制、更深思熟虑的执行方式，是还是不是？在你觉得舒服的范围内谈谈，因为我会假设片场的环境，嗯，不是假设，我知道，它们通常是私人的，
individual environments that are weird to redescribe.
But it just strikes me having, not many actors get to work with the same director,
six different projects.
I'd imagine you guys have a bit of a short.
shorthand and a real comfort in each other's style.
Oh, yeah.
I mean, I've learned so much from Chris.
He's completely kind of shaped my whole career.
奇怪的个人环境，很难描述。但让我印象深刻的是，没有多少演员能和同一个导演合作六个不同的项目。我想你们一定有一种速记，并且对彼此的风格感到非常舒适。哦，是啊。我是说，我从克里斯那里学到了很多。他完全塑造了我的整个职业生涯。
I mean, it's very clear, like working over 20 years.
But he's absolutely remarkable.
He is incredibly rigorous, incredibly precise.
But within that, there's fantastic freedom.
Yeah.
You know, there's only one camera and there's Chris,
and he's got this tiny little monitor.
and he has, like, puts back to the...
我是说，这很清楚，就像合作了20多年一样。但他绝对非凡。他极其严谨，极其精确。但在那之内，有极大的自由。是啊。你知道，只有一个摄像机，还有克里斯，他有一个小小的监视器。他有，就像，背对着……
Never two cameras.
Rarely unless there's a big set piece, you know?
But he has this tiny little thing, again, from, like, the 90s
that he watches a shitty little playback from the thing.
But he rarely is watching it because he's right beside the camera watching you.
And you'll never leave it.
He'll never leave a scene unless he feels like, you know,
you're happy and he's happy.
从来没有两台摄像机。除非有大的场景，否则很少见，你知道吗？但他有一个来自90年代的小东西，他看着那个东西播放的糟糕画面。但他很少看它，因为他就站在摄像机旁边看着你。他永远不会离开。除非他觉得，你知道，你满意了，他也满意了，否则他永远不会离开一个场景。
And it's...
I can't really explain how wonderful it is,
how focused is, how fast it is, but yet it never feels fast.
Like, we shot Oppenheimer in 59 days or something like that.
Wow.
With all that scope.
I know.
It's amazing.
而且……我无法解释它是多么美妙，它是多么专注，它是多么快，但它从不让人觉得快。就像，我们用59天左右的时间拍摄了《奥本海默》。哇。有那么大的规模。我知道。太神奇了。
So do you think that that speed or that efficiency, it just comes as a result of him
really being precise about knowing what he wants, what he needs, he's properly prepared,
and he doesn't hang around longer than he's gotten what he wants for that particular shot,
and off we go?
Exactly.
I mean, he's written the thing
and he knows every single frame
he's storyboarded it all in his head
所以你认为那种速度或效率，只是因为他非常精确地知道他想要什么，他需要什么，他准备充分，而且在他得到他想要的那个特定镜头后，他不会逗留更长时间，我们就走了？正是如此。我是说，他写了剧本，他知道每一个镜头，他在脑子里把所有东西都分镜了。
So it's, and the thing about Nolan movies is
If, when they used to be DVDs, there was never any extras
Because he shoots the script
This script is the script
There's no deleted scenes, there's no extra
It's the script
And he finishes every movie
Like ahead of schedule on the budget
所以，诺兰电影的特点是，如果，当它们还是DVD的时候，从来没有任何花絮，因为他拍摄的是剧本。这个剧本就是剧本。没有删除的场景，没有额外的。这就是剧本。而且他完成每部电影都提前于计划和预算。
Yeah, do you feel
Having him, yeah, it's pretty remarkable
Having him right next to camera
And obviously you guys
because you've worked so much together, there is a comfort there.
Do you get a comfort of having,
do you feel that comfort of having him right there
next to camera, close to you?
是啊，你觉得有他在身边，是啊，这很了不起，有他在摄像机旁边，显然你们因为合作了这么多，有一种舒适感。你有那种他在摄像机旁边，靠近你的舒适感吗？
Yeah.
There's no such thing as video village or like,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like when I stand next to you, Will.
Yeah.
You just comfort.
You can see it.
No, we're talking about comfort.
是啊。没有所谓的视频村之类的，是啊，是啊，是啊。就像我站在你旁边一样，威尔。是啊。你只是感到舒适。你可以看出来。不，我们在谈论舒适。
But I mean, so then I'm going to ask you,
so you feel that and you might, that's, yeah,
it's evident in your work that you do with him.
And so I wonder if when you go and you do work with other directors,
do you ever feel that like sort of sense of not detachment,
but sometimes if it is further, they are further away
or they are at Video Village and you don't have that sort of that proximity,
不，我们在谈论舒适。但我的意思是，所以我问你，所以你感觉到了，你可能，那是，是啊，这在你和他合作的作品中很明显。所以我很好奇，当你去和其他导演合作时，你是否会感觉到那种疏离感，不是疏离，但有时如果距离更远，他们离得更远，或者他们在视频村，你没有那种亲近感，
that relationship that's so close, do you feel the difference sometimes?
And I don't mean this to disparage other directors clearly.
Sure, no, I understand.
No, I think it's like what we were discussing earlier.
You know, over time, I think it's our duty to be really,
really, really flexible, isn't it?
Because if you come on one set with us,
and this is the only way I will work.
那种如此亲密的关系，你有时会感觉到区别吗？我这么说并不是为了贬低其他导演，显然。当然，不，我明白。不，我认为这就像我们之前讨论的那样。你知道，随着时间的推移，我认为我们的职责是变得非常、非常、非常灵活，不是吗？因为如果你和我们一起进入一个片场，这是我唯一的工作方式。
Some directors love to rehearse.
Some directors don't love to rehearse.
Some directors love, have everybody look at the monitor
and chat and others, you know, don't do that.
So you have to kind of bend to their approach, I find.
And I love doing that.
Like, you know, I don't particularly love rehearsing on film,
but if there's a director that insists on it,
有些导演喜欢排练。有些导演不喜欢排练。有些导演喜欢让每个人都看监视器聊天，而其他人，你知道，不那样做。所以我发现你必须顺应他们的方法。我喜欢这样做。就像，你知道，我不特别喜欢在电影中排练，但如果有导演坚持要这样做，
I'll go for it, you know?
because it's their vision and I'm just there to serve the vision.
So I kind of like that at the adventure of it.
And I'm sure you guys are all the same.
You know, it's like, it's always like a new circuses.
And every time you get a new job, it's like this new circus and what's it going to involve?
And what are, you know, so I like that.
For sure.
我会去做的，你知道吗？因为那是他们的愿景，我只是在那里服务于这个愿景。所以我有点喜欢那种冒险的感觉。我相信你们也都一样。你知道，这就像，它总是像一个新的马戏团。每次你得到一份新工作，它就像这个新的马戏团，它会涉及什么？会有什么，你知道，所以我喜欢那样。当然。
We'll be right back.
And back to the show.
How do you like affecting the health of that?
circus, the harmony of that environment, depending on your level of influence on that set.
Like, you know, just even the Nolan films, for example, there are some where you're a part of an
ensemble and then like Oppenheimer, you're the lead and you're, you're, you're, you can, you can,
you can affect the environment.
Pecky blinders, you know, again, sort of the, the captain and also in a, in a producer,
我们马上回来。回到节目。你如何影响那个马戏团的健康，那个环境的和谐，取决于你在那个片场的影响力水平？就像，你知道，即使是诺兰的电影，例如，有些你是群戏的一部分，然后像《奥本海默》，你是主角，你可以，你可以，你可以影响环境。《浴血黑帮》，你知道，又是那种，队长，也是一个制片人，
position as well. Do you enjoy that sort of leadership position or do you like to disappear
and just be sort of part of the team and be like a soldier? I think it's a bit of both really, isn't
that? Because it's funny you say soldier because the whole like the whole film set is based
off like the old military kind of setup, isn't it? Like, you're your director and your first AD
and your second AD and your third AD and you know, everyone's got number one in the college,
you're number two in the call. You know, it's it has to work. And it has to work.
like that and you know
and everything comes from the top I think
职位也是。你喜欢那种领导职位吗？还是你喜欢消失，只是成为团队的一部分，像个士兵？我想这真的是两者兼有，不是吗？因为你说士兵很有趣，因为整个电影片场都是基于那种旧的军事设置，不是吗？就像，你的导演，你的第一副导演，你的第二副导演，你的第三副导演，你知道，每个人在通告单上都有编号，你是二号。你知道，它必须运作。它必须像那样运作，你知道，一切都来自高层，我想，
you know the atmosphere and the
ambiance and the vibe and the energy
always is percolates down
from the leaders like the producers
and the director and the lead actors down
to how everyone so I think
it's always nice to
I love to have a set where people are having a bit of fun
你知道，气氛、氛围、氛围和能量总是从领导者那里渗透下来，比如制片人、导演和主演，渗透到每个人身上，所以我认为拥有一个人们玩得开心的片场总是好的。
and a bit of crack and crack
in the Irish vernacular
yeah yeah yeah yeah
we were with you we were with you
okay I could
Oh, boy.
Killian Murphy loves crack.
We've got our, yep.
还有一点爱尔兰式的幽默，爱尔兰语中的“crack”。是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊，我们和你在一起，我们和你在一起，好吧，我能，天哪。基里安·墨菲喜欢“crack”。我们有我们的，是的。
Killion, how do you speak about healthy?
How do you stay so fit?
You're always like, you're, I know you're younger than us, but.
I think it's crack.
Is it not?
He just told us.
Because you have kids too, right?
You're constantly working.
基里安，你谈论健康吗？你是怎么保持这么好的身材的？你总是，你，我知道你比我们年轻，但是。我想是“crack”。不是吗？他刚才告诉我们了。因为你也有孩子，对吧？你一直在工作。
You're constantly on the go.
But you're in, like, incredible shape.
Will looks pretty good.
He does.
Oh, thanks, man.
That's bronzer.
A lot of that's bronze.
Yeah, it is.
你一直在奔波。但你的状态，就像，令人难以置信。威尔看起来不错。他确实。哦，谢谢，伙计。那是古铜色。很多是古铜色。是啊，确实。
I just sprayed it on.
No, I think all of you guys are very well maintained.
I think it's kind of part of the job, isn't it?
Unfortunately, or fortunately, I don't know.
Well, there's another part of that Wikipedia, incredible hints I got.
There was, is it true that you, to avoid mad cow disease, you went vegetarian.
Then you started eating, then you started eating meat to bulk up for Piki Blind.
and then you stopped eating and you're back to vegetarian for,
我只是喷了上去。不，我想你们所有人都保养得很好。我想这是工作的一部分，不是吗？不幸的是，或者幸运的是，我不知道。好吧，维基百科上还有一部分，我得到了令人难以置信的提示。有，是真的吗？为了避免疯牛病，你变成了素食主义者。然后你开始吃，然后你开始吃肉来为《浴血黑帮》增肌，然后你停止吃肉，你又回到了素食主义者，为了，
it didn't give me the reason for the return.
But do they have it right so far?
That's more or less accurate.
I met my wife when I was 20 and she's been a vegetarian all the life.
So I was kind of became a vegetarian then.
And then I did kind of, so it was more out of convenience than of any real sort of, you know,
opposition to it.
But now I do do it because I don't really want to eat animals.
它没有给我回归的原因。但他们到目前为止说对了吗？这或多或少是准确的。我20岁时遇到了我的妻子，她一生都是素食主义者。所以我当时就变成了素食主义者。然后我确实有点，所以这更多是出于方便，而不是出于任何真正的，你知道，反对它。但现在我这样做是因为我真的不想吃动物。
And if you were to, you would make ends meet.
Thank you, Will.
And that's our episode, everybody.
Thank you for joining us.
Wonderful book.
We have made the two pieces of string connect at the bottom.
No, but you know, that whole bulking up thing,
I know I'm all over the place,
如果你要的话，你会收支平衡的。谢谢你，威尔。这就是我们的节目，各位。感谢你们加入我们。很棒的书。我们已经把两根绳子在底部连接起来了。不，但你知道，整个增肌的事情，我知道我到处乱说，
but I saw this documentary once
because I went vegetarian for a year,
to try to lower my cholesterol,
and it only dropped one point
after 12 months of eating nothing but like,
you know, sticks and berries, yeah.
Wasn't that long ago.
But I watched this documentary
但我曾经看过这个纪录片，因为我吃了一年的素食，试图降低胆固醇，但在吃了12个月除了，你知道，树枝和浆果之外什么都不吃之后，它只下降了一点。没过多久。但我看了这个纪录片，
when I was doing it,
and they made a point that you don't need meat to bulk up
because they made a point that, like,
gorillas are vegetarians,
rhinoceros,
girat, like, these huge animals,
all they eat are leaves.
Yeah, you're absolutely right there.
当我做的时候，他们指出你不需要肉来增肌，因为他们指出，就像，大猩猩是素食主义者，犀牛，长颈鹿，像这些巨大的动物，它们只吃叶子。是啊，你说得完全对。
I do that.
The update is that I am now, like, I've always been pescatarian and I don't eat any meat.
So that's the Wikipedia update.
So this fish?
We'll add that in there today.
Thanks.
You say you do do the fish?
I do do the fish, yes.
我这样做。更新是，我现在，就像，我一直是个鱼素主义者，我不吃任何肉。所以这就是维基百科的更新。所以这个鱼？我们今天会把它加进去。谢谢。你说你吃鱼？我确实吃鱼，是的。
Right, right.
And you're entirely right.
It's very possible if you need to do that to do it through plant protein, of course.
I don't know.
I was just being an idiot back then.
I'm still an idiot.
All right, let's talk to me about Peaky Blinders.
Now, just how long did you have been doing, how long did you, sorry, Jay,
对，对。而且你是完全正确的。如果你需要这样做，当然可以通过植物蛋白来做到。我不知道。我当时只是个白痴。我现在还是个白痴。好吧，跟我谈谈《浴血黑帮》。现在，你做了多久，你做了多久，抱歉，杰，
how long did you do Peaky Blinders before,
how long have been living in the world of Peaky Blinders?
So we did the show on and off for, since two, two, we shot the first season in the end of 2012.
So on and off.
Wow, 14 years.
So which I worked out was like a quarter of my life.
Yeah.
你在《浴血黑帮》的世界里生活了多久？所以我们断断续续地做了这个节目，从二，二，我们在2012年底拍摄了第一季。所以断断续续。哇，14年。所以我算出来这大概是我生命的四分之一。是啊。是啊。
And how have you, I'm sure.
you have enjoyed because you could have left it earlier.
But you have undoubtedly enjoyed the progression of Tommy
and shaping his growth along with Stephen Knight, yes.
Yes, but I'm curious to know about you guys as well,
because people ask me this stuff and, you know, that old showbiz adage,
like, you know, don't quit a hit.
是啊。你是怎么，我相信。你很享受，因为你本可以更早离开。但你无疑享受了汤米的进步，并与斯蒂芬·奈特一起塑造了他的成长，对吧？是的，但我对你们也很感兴趣，因为人们问我这些事情，你知道，那句古老的演艺圈格言，就像，你知道，不要退出热门节目。
Like, so when, like, if something is working,
and people, you know, a lot of journalists will say,
oh, it must be, you know, hard going back playing the sink.
It's amazing writing.
Well, if it's incredibly high quality, like what you guys have there,
and the film, my God, took it to even a higher level of production value
and cinematic pleasures, just unbelievably well directed and shot and scored and performed and lit.
I mean, what a film.
就像，所以当，就像，如果某件事在运作，人们，你知道，很多记者会说，哦，回去演这个角色一定很难。这是了不起的写作。好吧，如果它有极高的质量，就像你们在那里拥有的那样，而且电影，天哪，把它提升到了更高的制作价值和电影乐趣，简直是令人难以置信地导演、拍摄、配乐和表演，灯光也很好。我是说，多棒的电影啊。
But yes, amen.
If you've got a gig in this business,
stick with it.
These people that like quit their series job
because they want to be open
for all the feature opportunities
that they feel might be just around the corner.
It's like, no ding-dong.
但是的，阿门。如果你在这个行业有一份工作，坚持下去。那些因为想为他们觉得可能就在拐角处的电影机会而腾出时间，就辞掉系列剧工作的人。这就像，不，笨蛋。
You got time for those too.
I love that character of yours.
The guy who talks like this,
who does the thing that did.
I want to be freed up for features.
Like, give me.
Yeah, exactly.
But also, I think the thing that those people forget is that the features people are all watching the show.
你也有时间做那些。我喜欢你的那个角色。那个说话像这样的人，做那个做那个的人。我想为电影腾出时间。就像，给我。是啊，正是如此。但我也认为，那些人忘记的是，电影界的人都在看这个节目。
Right.
Yeah.
And thinking, of course.
Right.
Wouldn't they be great in my film?
Yeah.
Right, right.
Killing, do you spend a lot of time in the States or are you happy where you are?
对。是啊。并想，当然。对。他们不适合我的电影吗？是啊，对，对。基里安，你花很多时间在美国吗？还是你对你现在的地方很满意？
I do come over for work.
I've never lived other than for jobs.
For jobs.
So you love Ireland?
Well, I lived in London for a long time for like we lived here for 14.
years. Oh, you live in London now? I'm sorry. No, I'm sorry. Sorry, we're back in Ireland
now for about 10 years, but we did live in London for 14. And then before that, we're kind of like,
you know, wherever work would take me, I guess. Why do you ask, Sean, do you have a B,
我确实会为了工作过来。除了工作，我从来没住过。为了工作。所以你喜欢爱尔兰？好吧，我在伦敦住了很长时间，就像我们在这里住了14年。哦，你现在住在伦敦？对不起。不，对不起。抱歉，我们现在回到爱尔兰大约10年了，但我们确实在伦敦住了14年。然后在那之前，我们有点像，你知道，无论工作带我去哪里，我想。你为什么问，肖恩，你有一个Airbnb吗？
Airbnb? Well, no, it'll be nice to have a. You got a rental that you were just pay off
the mortgage, just a cover cost, right? And what can you offer them? Housekeeper comes twice a week?
Did the occupants just take off on you? I just think first and last in a deposit. We're good.
No, because, no, I don't know, I'm always curious because I love it where you are,
and I get, I get the draw to both.
I mean, America is obviously incredible.
Yeah, but we're kind of like itinerant, aren't we?
You just have to follow the work, and that's the nature of it.
好吧，不，有一个会很好。你有一个出租房，你只是还清抵押贷款，只是覆盖成本，对吧？你能给他们提供什么？管家一周来两次？住户只是从你那里搬走了？我只是觉得第一个和最后一个月付押金。我们很好。不，因为，不，我不知道，我总是很好奇，因为我喜欢你所在的地方，我明白，我明白两者的吸引力。我是说，美国显然是不可思议的。是啊，但我们有点像流浪者，不是吗？你必须跟随工作，这就是它的本质。
Yeah, we're in the circus, as you say.
Yeah, and you kind of, circus.
My friend once called it the Circus of the Unemployable.
I think it was a very good phrase.
That is.
The thing I was going to ask you about
doing multiple seasons,
years of the same character
是啊，我们在马戏团，正如你所说。是啊，你有点，马戏团。我的朋友曾经称它为“失业者的马戏团”。我认为这是一个非常好的短语。确实是。我要问你关于连续多年扮演同一个角色的事情，
is,
you know,
how much of you enjoyed having that character grow
with you because of you?
Has Killian grown
through what you've been experimenting with,
with Tommy?
I mean,
是，你知道，你有多享受让那个角色和你一起成长，因为你？基里安是否通过你在汤米身上尝试的东西而成长了？我是说，
I'm sure there's a,
there's a yes to all of this.
So I'm not positive what the question is,
which is a habit of mine.
I know what you mean.
I know I think it's a good question.
And honestly, I don't really have a really good answer, though,
我相信这一切都有一个肯定的答案。所以我不太确定问题是什么，这是我的一个习惯。我知道你的意思。我知道你的意思。我知道我认为这是一个好问题。老实说，我真的没有一个很好的答案，虽然，
because we've just finished it and it's just coming out.
And I think need a little bit of distance to reflect.
I think it's what my initial kind of response to it
is that it was a massive gift
to be able to tap that vein of writing
and for it to stay that good.
And for it to,
because it was this little show on BBC 2 on a Sunday night
因为我们刚刚完成了它，它刚刚出来。而且我认为需要一点距离来反思。我想我最初的反应是，能够挖掘那条写作脉络，并且让它保持那么好，是一份巨大的礼物。而且因为它，因为它只是BBC 2周日晚上的一部小节目，
that, you know,
no one had any expectations for it.
I had no promotion or anything like that.
And it was genuinely made by fans on the internet
telling each other to watch it.
Yeah. Yeah.
It just grew and grew one of those kind of beautiful,
a kind of freaks that happened sometimes in our business
你知道，没有人对它有任何期望。没有任何宣传之类的。而且它确实是由网上的粉丝互相告诉对方去看而制作的。是啊。是啊。它只是成长，成长，那种美丽的，那种有时在我们行业发生的怪胎之一，
where people just love it.
And then the show gets confidence.
Yeah, it's because, I mean, I would think it was because it took such a distinct point of
you.
You weren't sort of pandering to a huge audience.
You know, you were sort of like, we're going to make the show that we really like.
We're going to shoot it the way we want to shoot it.
We're going to put this music in there that we really love.
人们只是喜欢它。然后节目就有了信心。是啊，这是因为，我是说，我会认为这是因为它采取了如此独特的观点。你并没有迎合庞大的观众。你知道，你有点像，我们要制作我们真正喜欢的节目。我们要以我们想要的方式拍摄它。我们要把我们真正喜欢的音乐放进去。
And hopefully enough people like it to just keep us on the air, but we're not looking to be
some massive hit.
and that type of specificity and commitment
actually yielded a real fervent fan base.
As opposed to sort of trying to retrofit,
trying to go like, we want to make a show
that hits all this audience, and so how can we,
and that's a recipe for disaster.
希望有足够多的人喜欢它，让我们继续播出，但我们并不想成为什么巨大的热门。那种特殊性和承诺实际上产生了一个真正狂热的粉丝群。而不是试图改造，试图去，就像，我们想制作一个吸引所有观众的节目，所以我们怎么能，那是一个灾难的配方。
I wonder, Killing, were there moments during various seasons of the show
and certainly before the film,
were there moments you're like, this is it, this is the last one,
and then it happened again?
Like, did you ever have those where you felt like,
or was it always open-ended, like we're going to do more?
Well, they wouldn't, they were never,
like we only got one series and then we were hoping we'd get recommissioned,
我想知道，基里安，在节目的各个季节，当然在电影之前，有没有那么一刻你觉得，就是这个了，这是最后一部，然后它又发生了？就像，你有没有过那些你觉得，或者它总是开放式的，就像我们要拍更多？好吧，它们不会，它们从来没有，就像我们只得到了一季，然后我们希望我们能得到续订，
you know, I think we did maybe four and five, one after the other.
I can't really recall.
But he all, like Steve always had it in his head,
so the series begins at the end of World War I,
and he always had it in his head that it would end at the beginning,
sort of the beginning of World War II
and he's achieved that.
So that was such a, like no one had,
你知道，我想我们可能连续拍了四和五。我真的记不清了。但他总是，就像史蒂夫总是把它记在脑子里，所以系列剧开始于第一次世界大战结束时，他总是把它记在脑子里，它会结束于开始，就像第二次世界大战的开始，他实现了这一点。所以那是一个如此的，就像没有人有，
like there's lots and lots of,
you know, films about the First World War
and many, many, many films
about the Second World War,
but not so many films or TV shows
that deal with Britain between the wars.
So that's where he said it.
And in Birmingham, which is like the second city
就像有很多很多，你知道，关于第一次世界大战的电影，以及许多、许多、许多关于第二次世界大战的电影，但没有那么多处理两次大战之间英国的电影或电视节目。所以这就是他设置它的地方。而且在伯明翰，它是英国的第二大城市，
in the UK and
has,
its very own specific and unique history.
And so,
I think because, like you say, it didn't have these ambitions to be this huge show,
but yet because it was so unique that people came to it, I don't know.
I just don't know why.
Yeah, well, if we all knew it made a hit, everything would be a hit.
并且有它自己非常具体和独特的历史。所以，我想因为，就像你说的，它没有成为这个巨大节目的野心，但因为它太独特了，人们来到它面前，我不知道。我只是不知道为什么。是啊，好吧，如果我们都知道它会成为热门，一切都会成为热门。
You are such a classy fellow.
I'm sure you'd be very hesitant to take any credit.
But I would guess that you can take some credit perhaps for,
for the incredibly, beautifully bold move of the music.
Herkos?
The music throughout the show, is that, is that something that, I mean, given your music
background, your current musical taste, I mean, it's just such a, it's such an exciting
sort of juxtaposition and, you know, this modern fucking punk rock throughout something
你真是个优雅的人。我相信你会非常犹豫是否要接受任何赞誉。但我猜你可能可以接受一些赞誉，也许是因为，因为音乐那令人难以置信的、美丽的、大胆的举动。赫科斯？整个节目中的音乐，是那个，是那个东西，我是说，鉴于你的音乐背景，你目前的音乐品味，我是说，这只是一个，这是一个令人兴奋的并置，你知道，这种现代的该死的朋克摇滚贯穿于某件事，
that is set in, you know, World War I.
is just great.
It was a, that was a bit of a kind of a, I guess, like a big swing at the time.
And Otto Bathurst directed the first three series.
And he put that Nick Cave tune, that Red Right Hand right at the beginning of the,
and it was incredibly anachronistic.
And it shouldn't have worked for some reason, it did.
And then we were kind of off.
设定在，你知道，第一次世界大战。简直太棒了。那是一个，那有点像，我猜，就像当时的一个大动作。奥托·巴瑟斯特执导了前三季。他把那首尼克·凯夫的曲子，《红右手》放在了开头，它非常不合时宜。它本不应该奏效，但出于某种原因，它奏效了。然后我们就开始了。
And then all these artists threw out it like PJ Harvey and like David Bowie,
Radiohead.
and everybody started, you know, wanting to have their music on the show
and giving us original music.
And it's been kind of remarkable.
It's just an really privilege.
For a music nerd, like me, you know.
Yeah.
然后所有这些艺术家都抛弃了它，比如PJ哈维和像大卫·鲍伊，电台司令。每个人都开始，你知道，想要他们的音乐出现在节目中，并给我们原创音乐。这真是太了不起了。这真是一种特权。对于像我这样的音乐书呆子来说，你知道。是啊。
What a treat.
All right.
Well, I'm assuming you've answered this question a million times,
but putting Peky Blinders to bed, I will ask you,
are you good, I'm sure you're going to take a big part of him with you.
Do you, do you, are you going to miss him?
Are you going to miss playing that, that character?
It's just been, you just done so much work in that skin.
多好的款待。好吧。好吧，我假设你已经回答过这个问题一百万次了，但把《浴血黑帮》收尾，我会问你，你还好吗，我相信你会带走他很大一部分。你，你，你会想念他吗？你会想念扮演那个，那个角色吗？这只是，你只是在那层皮下做了太多的工作。
I guess I suppose I probably will.
Yeah.
I don't think about it.
What do you guys feel about those long-running shows and those characters?
I'm curious to know.
Just turn the page, right?
Yeah.
But do you actually feel, I mean, are you extremely unsentimental
我想我大概会吧。是啊。我没想过。你们对那些长寿的节目和那些角色有什么感觉？我很好奇。翻过这一页，对吧？是啊。但你真的觉得，我是说，你极其缺乏感伤，
or do you have a great affection for them?
My personal either limits or strategy or style or whatever is to find that character inside of me.
You know, it's usually way over on one side or the other of what my goalposts are, you know, the limits of who I am.
So that person's always inside of me.
So I'll always carry that character with me a bit.
I feel like if it's outside my goalpost, then I get into acting.
So I got to find, you know, there would there would.
be a
还是你对他们有很大的感情？我个人的限制或策略或风格或任何东西，就是在我内心找到那个角色。你知道，它通常在我目标柱的一边或另一边，你知道，我作为谁的限制。所以那个人总是存在于我内心。所以我总是会带着那个角色一点。我觉得如果它在我的目标柱之外，那么我就进入了表演。所以我必须找到，你知道，那里会有，
version of him
inside me somewhere.
What about you two fellows?
Yeah, I'm
proud and excited that
the fans love the character I played
for so many years.
But for me personally, yeah, like Jason
他版本在我内心的某个地方。你们两个伙计呢？是啊，我很自豪也很兴奋，粉丝们喜欢我扮演了这么多年的角色。但对我个人来说，是啊，就像杰森
just said, ready to move
on after that. Yeah.
I'm not sentimental in that way.
Yeah. Yeah, neither am I, yeah.
You're happy to say kind of goodbye,
nice knowing you next.
Yeah. I think so. Yeah, and very
proud of it and like you say like really proud that it had such an impact and that the people
刚才说的，在那之后准备好继续前进了。是啊。我在这方面不感伤。是啊。是啊，我也不是，是啊。你很高兴说再见，很高兴认识你，下一个。是啊。我想是这样。是啊，而且非常自豪，就像你说的，真的为它产生了如此大的影响而自豪，而且人们
invested so much but yeah yeah it have to have a forward momentum it's more for me usually it's the
people I've worked with doing it that it's really tragic that we have to get used to saying goodbye
to that's an odd muscle that we all unfortunately have to have to have to strengthen is
saying goodbye to these families that we're constantly creating on sets that's the strange thing
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
You know, when you run into someone,
I was just thinking about you run into people
投入了这么多，但是啊，是啊，它必须有向前的动力，对我来说通常是和我一起工作的人，我们不得不习惯说再见，这真的很悲惨，那是一块奇怪的肌肉，我们所有人不幸都必须，必须，必须加强，那就是对我们在片场不断创造的这些家庭说再见，那才是奇怪的事情。是啊，是啊，是啊。你知道，当你遇到某人时，我刚才在想你遇到人，
that you worked with on something really intensely
and you see them like at a restaurant or out of the street
or at something else, you know,
and I don't even just mean actors like anybody
who's part of the filmmaking process,
a production designer or whomever,
and you see them, you're like, and you go, hey,
and you've got this, you've got this like really intense
你和他们一起工作过，非常紧张，你在餐馆或街上或别的地方看到他们，你知道，我甚至不只是指演员，就像任何参与电影制作过程的人，制作设计师或任何人，你看到他们，你就像，你去，嘿，你有这个，你有这个，就像非常紧张。
part of your life where you had this real
where you were both doing this creative endeavor.
You're like, hey,
But you've always got that, you know what I mean?
And your family has no idea who these people are.
And you've spent more time with them in the last few years than you have your actual family.
And they've never met them.
And they bring you such joy in that moment when you see them.
在你生命中的那段时光里，你们共同投入了一项创造性的事业。你会觉得，嘿，那种感觉一直都在，你明白我的意思吗？你的家人根本不知道这些人是谁，而你在过去几年里与他们相处的时间比与真正的家人相处的时间还要多。他们从未见过面，但当你见到他们时，他们会给你带来巨大的快乐。
Yeah, yeah.
Yes, and then it's instant there's no like getting to know you again.
It's just you're straight back into it because you've been through the trenches.
Straight.
Well, we are two minutes over.
Yeah, parting shot, Shawnee?
No, I was just going to say, now when I run into you, Killing, we worked on this together.
We did.
是的，没错。而且那种感觉是瞬间产生的，不需要重新认识。你们直接就进入了状态，因为你们曾并肩作战。没错。好了，我们超时两分钟了。肖尼，最后有什么想说的吗？不，我只是想说，现在当我遇到你时，基里安，我们一起合作过这个项目。我们确实合作过。
So we have this moment and this experience together.
So when we run into each other.
Piki Blinders, the immortal man in select theaters already March 6th it was.
And on Netflix, March 20th, I highly recommend this thing.
And you can't fold laundry watching it either.
put the laundry down,
tuck in,
and enjoy every frame of this thing.
所以我们共同拥有这段时刻和经历。当我们再次相遇时，《浴血黑帮：不朽之王》已经在部分影院上映，日期是3月6日。3月20日上线Netflix，我强烈推荐这部作品。看的时候你可没法叠衣服，把衣服放下，坐下来，享受这部电影的每一帧画面吧。
Incredible work done by
in front of them
behind the cameras.
It's just,
it's a stunning film.
Really.
Very kind.
It's lovely to chat to you guys.
台前幕后的工作人员都付出了令人难以置信的努力。这真是一部令人惊叹的电影。真的。太客气了。很高兴能和你们聊天。
I had loads of questions
to ask you guys.
Oh, let's start.
Get yourself a podcast and invite us on.
They're handing them out.
We haven't had a gossip.
Yeah.
Oh, we got to gossip all day long.
我本来还有很多问题想问你们。哦，我们开始吧。你们自己开个播客，然后邀请我们去。现在播客到处都是。我们还没聊够八卦呢。是啊，我们本来可以聊一整天八卦的。
You can gossip after I leave.
Yeah.
Such a pleasure to meet you.
What a pleasure.
Been a big fan for a long, long time.
Such a big fan.
Yeah, same, such a big fan.
等我走了你们再聊吧。是啊。很高兴见到你们。真是荣幸。我一直是你的忠实粉丝，很久很久了。我也是超级粉丝。是啊，我也是，超级粉丝。
Likewise, guys.
You're the man, Killian.
Lovely to chat to you all.
Yeah.
We'll do it again.
Enjoy your evening.
Get your slippers on.
Thanks.
彼此彼此，伙计们。你真是太棒了，基里安。很高兴和你们所有人聊天。是的，我们下次再聚。祝你们晚上愉快。穿上拖鞋休息吧。谢谢。
All right.
Bye, guys.
Yeah, it's nearly bad time now.
All right.
Bye, buddy.
Good night.
Bye-bye.
Bye.
好的。再见，伙计们。是啊，快到睡觉时间了。好的。再见，伙计。晚安。拜拜。再见。
Well, there he is.
And you know, the most remarkable thing about his talent,
that accent, completely fake.
He is actually from, yeah.
Yeah.
No kidding.
Yeah, can't in Ohio.
好了，他就是这样。你知道他才华中最引人注目的地方吗？那个口音，完全是假的。他其实来自……是啊。是啊。别开玩笑了。是啊，来自俄亥俄州的坎顿。
Why would he?
Can't in Ohio.
Yeah, his dad actually was one of the people that helped build the NFL Hall of Fame.
Oh, that's amazing.
Yeah, yeah.
No, this is a character he hasn't dropped for years.
Wow.
I mean, that's deep.
他为什么要那样？俄亥俄州的坎顿。是啊，他父亲其实是帮助建造NFL名人堂的人之一。哦，那太棒了。是啊，是啊。不，这是一个他多年来一直没丢掉的角色设定。哇。我的意思是，这太深了。
That's amazing.
Deep, deep.
So, wow.
What a fella.
You know what?
Yeah, he's so good.
Christopher Nolan and him, like, you kind of think of those two together.
And I was trying to think of who else are there.
那太神奇了。深，太深了。哇。真是个了不起的人。你知道吗？是啊，他太棒了。克里斯托弗·诺兰和他，你会把他们俩联系在一起。我还在想还有谁是这样的。
There's a lot of them, like, Tim Burton and Johnny.
Depp
Yeah, Leonardo DiCaprio
and Martin Scorsese.
Sure.
Yeah.
Did he really
Scorsese.
有很多这样的组合，比如蒂姆·波顿和约翰尼·德普，莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥和马丁·斯科塞斯。当然。是啊。他真的是斯科塞斯吗？
Yeah, and Tom Hanks
and Spielberg did a bunch
didn't they?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's one of them.
Here comes a joke, right?
I thought that was leading to a buy,
but no, that was a real observation.
是啊，汤姆·汉克斯和斯皮尔伯格也合作了很多次，不是吗？是啊，是啊，是啊。他是其中之一。笑话要来了，对吧？我以为那是在引出什么梗，但没有，那是一个真实的观察。
It was.
He was being sincere
while he searches for a buy.
Where do you go?
Is there a buy website?
I do have a bunch of
of buy thing.
but
确实。他在寻找梗的时候表现得很真诚。你去哪找？有什么专门找梗的网站吗？我确实有一堆梗，但是……
boy
Will you're showing
a lot of restraint
not doing any of the
by jokes at all
I know
shoot
oh
威尔，你忍住没讲任何关于“梗”的笑话，表现得很有克制力啊。我知道，该死，哦。
that's a good
Sean
oh Sean did you
Sean did you key it on one
did you get on
oh
what could be
you know
那是个好梗，肖恩。哦，肖恩，你抓住了吗？你抓住了吗？哦，那会是什么呢，你知道的……
I hope
I hope the movie
I can't wait
to see the movie
of our guest today
that's great
what's it called
it's called
我希望，我希望这部电影……我迫不及待想看我们今天嘉宾的电影了，那太棒了。它叫什么名字？它叫……
Peaky Binders
Smartless is
smartless is
100%
organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarf.
Smart. Less.
《浴血黑帮》。Smartless是由本内特·巴比科、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗伯·阿姆贾夫手工制作的100%有机艺术品。Smartless。